about is female like so when i first got
into the red pill it was very confusing
because i think that some of the
i don't want to say this is advice for
females but if you're a female like
listening to the red pill
it's very confusing because first they
tell you they don't want a girl with a
high body count i understand that not
gonna like fine i agree with that okay
then but then they also say like if a
girl doesn't sleep with you by the third
date to move on right and to me i'm like
you could do three dates in a week like
how are you gonna how are you gonna have
a girl that keeps a low body count if
she's sleeping with you with three dates
like that's so fast well this is i've
heard it's because
um i've been in a relationship for a
little bit so it could have just been
like i don't know maybe i haven't been
in like the dating scene long enough but
uh yeah that was my thought process
no no this is this is something this is
something we've gotten for a while man
um
so
the question you're asking is okay you
red pill guys don't want girls with a
high body count but then
if she's not banging after the third
date we move on so or they'll say well
listen you you don't want girls with a
high body count yet you're out here
smashing all these girls and adding to
their body count i i understand sorry
the second part because obviously like
you're gonna have sex with a girl that
you would never date i 100 i just went
to a pickup event where like guys are
like taught how to get laid it was like
the video's dropping this week you
should react to it and
um it's going to be fire guaranteed all
right all right
but like they like and i talked to these
guys because these are guys that take
home like three four girls a week yeah
and they tell me like there's a type of
girl they would take home but never be
seen in public yes so i i 100 understand
like there's a difference i understand
having sex is different for men and for
women i'm just asking like if a girl
wants to be taken seriously by that type
of guy
and you tell those type of guys don't
leave if she doesn't have sex by the
third date like it just seems like that
advice is counter-intuitive does that
make sense it makes perfect sense okay
and here's here's here's where girl now
here's where girls go wrong right okay
let's just say let's just say for the
sake of argument one of your 25 year old
virginal friends at your former church
in wisconsin let's just say she's a
virgin she's a good shape she's pretty
she needs a dude like me right i take
her out on the first date she doesn't
give it up second date she doesn't give
it up third date she doesn't give it up
now
at that point we would advise men to
leave you want to know why we advise men
to leave because we know that most girls
sleep around okay okay most girls sleep
around so if a girl and
i don't
we know most girls sleep around we can
dude we can look at a girl dude by the
third date just by the thing she tells
us i have a course called womanis you
can you can tell pretty quickly i've
reacted you've seen them i've reacted
i've seen yeah these are actually pretty
good and so we if a girl we know sleeps
around doesn't give it up after the
third date we're scooting because we
know she's giving it up to other guys or
she has in the past you're trying to get
sticker price for for for because
because then she's not attracted to you
it's the genuine desire there you go
there it is here's the thing here's the
thing let's say that i'm out on three
straight dates with your with your 25
year old virginal friend well guess what
if she's out with a guy like me she
really likes me and if and listen i've
tried three times she's like look
donovan i really like you but i'm not
having sex with you until we're in a
relationship
if after that she can she sends me good
morning texts hey i'm thinking about you
hey let's do something fun if she
continues to give me what i call plan a
attention which means there are no other
guys then guess what at that point i'm
thinking okay
this girl she claims she's a virgin
there are no other guys around her i
don't see any thirst trapped pictures on
instagram or in case maybe she's hit me
up all the time she's always over at my
place
i think i'll keep her around for a
little while that's the difference so so
when we tell guys to dip after the third
date she doesn't give it up we're
talking about we're talking about girls
who we know are hoes who have given up
on first dates plenty of times listen we
know you're 38 years old and and now you
know you're worth but guess what i'm not
about that i'm not about to pay that
price right
um so yeah that's that that's the
difference that's the difference between
the virginal girl and the girl because
we know most women sleep around and if
she doesn't sleep against the third day
she's not into you player move on
um so the next question i had